we're talking about the nhl yesterday
right
and hl just announced that they will not
be sending
their players to the olympics nhl uh the
players union agreed to it they just
said we're not selling players to the
olympics this is an ap news right
commissioner gary baton made me made the
announcement wednesday making it
official what seemed inevitable in
recent days when a rash of positive
cobia 19 test results caused several
teams to shut down the list of postponed
games balloon 250 give the profound
disruption to the nhl's regular season
schedule caused by recent covert related
events olympic participation is no
longer feasible bateman said the league
will use the previously scheduled
february 6th through 22nd olympic break
to make up those games and others that
need to be rescheduled okay great here's
the guy that makes a decision saying
we're not going there so who's going to
be playing just lower level people going
to be playing for
i like when sometimes decisions are made
from the top
you hear who complains you hear who
doesn't complain and you move with the
people that are supportive of the
decision that's being made i support
doors i have a question is that just
americans or is that any nhl players
that means canadians scandinavians
russia everyone's affected so you're
telling me that vladimir putin is just
going to go around these pistols exactly
so i don't know if this is going to work
it's okay it's going to work you think
so if you play in the nhl is vladimir
putin going to pay players 7.8 million a
year yeah maybe if you disagree with
putin maybe you don't have legs
[Music]
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]